l'intelligence artificielle est
désormais partout elle permet aux
ordinateurs de reconnaître la voix même
différents accents les visages
l'écriture manuscrite et elle débarque
aujourd'hui dans les porcheries dont le
rang saint gabriel nord à sainte-marie
de beauce c'est oui vivent
habituellement en groupe et en liberté
si elles sont en cage c'est pour une
dizaine de jours seulement le temps de
procéder à l'insémination artificielle
réussir la saillie au bon moment est un
travail de grande précision qui échoue
malheureusement deux fois sur trois mais
depuis quelques mois dans la porcherie
de luxe veilleux l'opération est
effectuée avec succès presque dix fois
sur dix
un équipement comme ça ça fait 35 ans
l'intelligence artificielle fait son
entrée dans la production porcine sur
les agissements des saillies saha utt
reste à venir
des caméras de surveillance ont filmé
les truies jour et nuit
c'est à la fois révolutionnaire est
normal on est rendu là
les images captées dans la maternité
sont enregistrés et analysés par
l'ordinateur
les résultats sont fournies en temps
réel à l'éleveur il reçoit les
indications nécessaires pour déterminer
le moment exact de l'insémination de la
truite à chaleur pour les semaines parce
que la charge à truyes de durée de 24 à
96 ans l'ovulation détruisant quatre
âges
pourtant les éleveurs connaissent bien
les signes de l'arrivée des chaleurs la
truie qui se fige en présence du verrat
les oreilles qu'il s'est bien droite
mais miser sur le moment pile de
l'ovulation c'est presque impossible un
coup de dé chaque fois qu'ils
nécessitent de la main d'oeuvre et se
soldent souvent par une perte d'argent à
chaque dose inutile l'équipe de jacques
labrecque a mis au point un système
capable d'analyser le comportement
particulier de chaque tweet car avec les
changements hormonaux
la routine de la truie et complètement
modifié est-ce que les truies et de boue
est-ce qu'il est couché est ce qu'elle
est assise à quelle fréquence à va
changer de peau ce truc comme ça
ensuite de ça on va faire la prédiction
du moment optimal pour l'insémination la
prédiction du moment optimal est
symbolisé par une ligne verte pour
rendre la chose encore plus complexe les
agissements diffèrent d'une truie à
l'autre si l'intérêt par jour pour les
labrecque de la beauce icaunaise son
production porcine
ils ont été éleveur inventeur de
machinerie spécialisée et avec la
génération de jacques lahaye et sont
devenus des chefs de file en
intelligence artificielle dont les pour
chedjou
mon grand père quand il commençait avec
des animaux y avait quelques cochons
quelques vaches puis s'était il
connaissait ces animaux comme je connais
mon frère comme je connais ma soeur
comme je connais mes parents il connaît
et sait exactement quel animal
réagissait comment dans quelles
situations qu'ils étaient capables de
redonner un soin personnalisé pour
chaque animal maintenant qu'avec les
fermes qui ont pris de l'ampleur
puis avec le manque de main d'oeuvre on
est tombé à une personne qui s'occupe de
dizaines de milliers de nouveaux
[Musique]
l'intelligence artificielle permet un
élevage de précision et une approche
individualisée
les algorithmes sont développées ici à
saint lambert de lauzon l'équipe examine
des images de porcs et de porcelets du
matin au soir
ils sont agronome programmeurs
spécialiste de l'intelligence
artificielle des sciences animales et de
la modélisation
ils parviennent à identifier chaque port
à partir de ces comportements
l'intelligence artificielle c'est la
capacité des ordinateurs maintenant à
apprendre des choses qui étaient
autrefois plutôt réservé à l'être humain
et c'est rien donc qu'une série de
calculs qui va interpréter des données
une autre application de l'intelligence
artificielle à la ferme
le calcul exact des ports qui se
déplacent en groupe comme ceci ça paraît
simple mais c'est plus complexe que l'on
pense
la première chose qu'il faut se demander
c'est est-ce qu'un humain est capable de
garder le compte des animaux quand il
passe comme ça dans un corridor
la réponse c'est très souvent non
[Musique]
à cap-saint-ignace l'éleveur pierre
tremblay en sait quelque chose
aujourd'hui il rassemble ces animaux
pour une livraison à l'abattoir
la façon de faire habituelle est la
suivante
l'éleveur les comptes à la ferme le
transporteur mes calculs à son tour et
l'abattoir aussi mais les trois
n'arrivent pas toujours les mêmes
résultats
la bande à tchô l'ararat g
c'est un peu gros que j'ai compris c'est
hugo de la barre c'est tout bête
d'abattoirs laborde
alors dans ces conditions qui dit vrai à
environ 200 dollars le port une erreur
de calcul de quelques bêtes représente
beaucoup d'argent
même avec de l'expérience c'est facile
de se tromper c'est des animaux un
attentat anti comptait 10 le one nacarat
c'était sans dans l'allée lancar à
lautard plouvien secret très malin
dorénavant chez pierre tremblay le
dénombrement se fait grâce à la caméra
branchée à cet ordinateur le logiciel
reconnaît chaque port et effectuer le
comptage
[Musique]
votre système fonctionne vous convient
très bien donc vous voyez quand il ya un
animal qui passe des comptes et en plus
si jamais un animal passer dans l'autre
sens ce qui se raconte et en négatif
lors des simples d'un point à 77
c'est ça qu'on a aussi reconnu comme fut
excellent accélère comme la technologie
est capable de suivre à la trace les
ports en liberté
les possibilités de l'intelligence
artificielle peuvent être énormes
si l'animal est malade s'il manque d'eau
s'il survient une bataille l'éleveur
peut recevoir une alerte et intervenir
sur le champ donc si on est capable
d'alerter l'éleveur de problèmes
potentiels dans sa ferme
mais on va pas c'est vraiment un autre
niveau on va passer à un niveau de
prévention plutôt que d'agir en réaction
toujours à des problèmes quand le
problème est très répandue ainsi au lieu
d' administré le médicament à toute la
porcherie l'éleveur pourrait avoir une
approche ciblée
quand on parle par exemple de le
problème de résistance aux antibiotiques
à l'échelle mondiale ben on peut être
une solution parmi tant d'autres pour
aider à s'améliorer en tant que société
avec l'intelligence artificielle les
spécialistes de saint lambert de lauzon
développe une approche plus fine animal
par animal pour les 7 millions de porcs
produits chaque année au québec et il y
a lieu de rêver pour l'immense cheptel
mondial et on a dédié aux joueurs qui
proviennent de la chine pays qui disent
qu'ils s'intéressent présentement à
l'intelligence artificielle appliquée au
domaine agricole
donc faut rester à l'affût mais tant
qu'on n'a pas vu les résultats concrets
ben on peut dire que le terrain de jeu
est encore le nom
pour leur part le vieux et pierre
tremblay après une trentaine d'années
dans la production porcine vient de
faire un grand bond en avant
et pas question de revenir en arrière
c'est pour faire
[Musique]
il